[Music]  you're so exciting to work with Zack  he's been to many musicals but he hadn't  done her for at least 10 years and he I  think was really excited really  determined to do something different to  what it done before he just had this  feeling there was something about this  project that felt special it was really  wonderful  watching friendship build and watching  the effect that I had on the number  [Music]  the song by the N becomes a celebration  as they head into the circus and you see  Philips mine kind of blown by what he's  agreed to obviously the button at the  end of the song has him seen zendaya for  the very first time literally falling in  love like that's just an amazing arc to  have over the course of one song  [Music]  [Applause]